ce soir l'oubli de lino Sapporo
Jamie Shaw Dupree ou diluant la Mafia
et associé avec saputo l'homme le plus riche du
Québec a toujours nié tout lien
avec la Mafia une affirmation qu'il répète dans son
autobiographie publiée l'automne dernier nous avons
respecté la loi gardé nos distances avec
les organisations criminelles  il devait
savoir qui était Bonanno il savait que
Bonanno avait une relation secrète avec
sa compagnie Joe Bonanno était le
parrain de la mafia aux états-unis  son adresse est le 255
et cet agent de l'Arizona qui a
enquêté sur lui nous aidera à combler
certaines des lacunes de l'histoire de lino saputo,
nous récupérons les notes selon lesquelles il avait un
intérêt financier caché dans le
fromage saputo et à travers des documents récemment découverts
, nous vous le dirons  sur d'autres
relations que lino saputo avait avec des
criminels
[Musique]
nous révélerons également des zones d'ombre dans la
vie d'autres membres de sa famille qui ont
assisté à un grand événement chez les
Rizzuto, qui étaient les
chefs de la mafia canadienne à l'époque où
je suis  Mahima Denis
bienvenue à uncapped c'est un
livre intrigant dans ses mémoires l'un des
hommes d'affaires les plus riches du Canada raconte l'histoire
de son ascension de la misère à la richesse et il
consacre un chapitre entier aux allégations
de ses liens avec la mafia la
police de madison est mobilisée un peu
notoire depuis plus  depuis deux ans notre
confrère guitariste Pouliot
collectionne des documents sur lino saputo
et les membres de sa famille
waha réputation Tierney je raconte les
apparitions a oconee le sapp  La famille oro a
atteint le sternum d'affaires de
manière spectaculaire sapporo inc est maintenant la
plus grande entreprise laitière et fromagère au
canada et se classe deuxième aux États-
Unis l'entreprise québécoise saputo une
délicatesse
soprofesh ATLA entreprise américaine Stella
aliments elle est devenue un
empire international avec plus de  17 000 employés pâtes au
pesto - Kayla sous vide
horaire culinaire nous avons fait une boulangerie interétatique américaine semi-rationnelle
aujourd'hui la famille saputo vaut
environ six milliards de dollars avec sa
société phare saputo Inc mais ce
n'est qu'une fraction de leur fortune ces
immeubles emblématiques du centre-ville de Montréal
font partie des biens immobiliers les
supporters possédaient également l'équipe de soccer de Montréal
et ont des intérêts dans les industries du camionnage
et du bois une petite souris
sur vous lino Sapporo est retraité de
l'entreprise de fabrication de fromage il
consacre maintenant son temps à la philanthropie mais les
documents que nous avons trouvés brillent  une lumière sur
ce qui n'est pas dit dans l'
autobiographie de lino Sapporo  m Albany New York en
Arizona, nous avons découvert des secrets que le
milliardaire aurait pu espérer être
enterré pour toujours à 82 ans lino
sapporo a décidé qu'il était temps de raconter son
histoire alors que je repense à ma vie j'ai
réalisé à quel point ma jeunesse était importante pour
façonner mon  priorités et choix de vie
plus tard
il est né dans le village sicilien de
Monte leprae lino est le quatrième des huit
enfants nés de Maria et Giuseppe
saputo mon père était un homme d'affaires local
et un fromager de métier il était
fier de la qualité et du goût de  le
fromage qu'il fabriquait
mais la vie changeait dans son village
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale La Sicile a été laissée en
ruines notre village et la Sicile dans son ensemble ont
rapidement ressemblé au Far West la violence
était monnaie courante notre système de gouvernement
et notre modèle de gouvernance se sont effondrés créant un
vide de pouvoir que le local  mafia n'étaient
que trop heureux de remplir
[Musique]
les Sapporo ont décidé de fuir et, comme des
milliers d'autres Italiens à l'époque, se sont
mis à améliorer leur
vie à Ca  nada le 8 décembre 1952
nous sommes arrivés à Halifax où nous avons pris
le train pour Montréal
[Musique]
à Montréal au début des années 50 la
famille solidaire a commencé à gagner modestement sa
vie grâce à de petits boulots pour aider son
père à retourner à l'entreprise fromagère
lino  saputo a fait don de toutes ses économies
pour monter l'entreprise c'est l'histoire qu'il
raconte souvent comme lors de cette
conférence de presse en 2003 et beaucoup qui sont
encore ils gardent le manager dit devenu
inséparable d'un solennel une pilule a
propulsé le résultat de la Premier League en
septembre  1954 Giuseppe saputo Fe est
né, les affaires étaient bonnes et ils ont
rapidement pu échanger le vélo contre une
camionnette de livraison
. En 1957, notre entreprise, bien que
de taille encore modeste, s'était développée. Nous avons acheté la
propriété sur la huitième avenue dans le quartier semi-
coquille.
travaillait en bas
[Musique]
mais au début des années 60, des problèmes
sont survenus, les gangsters que la famille a laissés
en Italie étaient déjà bien établis en
tant que mafia à Montréal un  et il a été dirigé
avec une poignée IRA par Victor Oni l'homme
dans la Cadillac est Vince Enzo cutroni
il ne répond à personne au Canada l'essor
de la pizzeria avait conduit à une
concurrence féroce, en particulier de la part de types peu recommandables
certains de la
communauté italienne locale dans leur  désir de prendre le
contrôle du marché local, ils n'ont pas
hésité à recourir à la violence,
cela a conduit à ce que certains ont appelé la guerre du fromage
ou la guerre de la pizza.
crime
l'année 1963 a tenu les
enquêteurs de la police de Montréal particulièrement occupés les
pneus des camions ont été crevés incendie criminel commis à
l'arrière de l'installation acide sulfurique
mélangé à du lait en fermentation explosion
à l'intérieur de l'entrée principale
[Musique]
layna sapporo sera également victime de
ces gangsters en mai de  63 alors qu'il
livrait du fromage près de la Petite
Italie de Montréal, il a été brutalement battu dès que
je suis entré dans la cuisine.
Au sous-sol, alors que j'atteignais le
bas des escaliers, trois hommes
m'ont attaqué, l'un d'eux m'a humilié avec ce qui
ressemblait à une batte de baseball, ils ont dit
qu'ils voulaient que moi et ma compagnie hors du
commerce de fromage, j'ai été pétrifié quelques
minutes plus tard, ils se sont enfuis en me laissant  il
saignait sur le sol selon sa
version lino sapporo ne peut pas dire avec
certitude qui étaient ses agresseurs je
ne voulais pas spéculer sur l'
identité de mes agresseurs ou pire porter de
fausses accusations mais selon
les registres de la police des témoins dans le
restaurant ont reconnu le  voyous l'
un d'eux était Paulo Viola qui serait
éventuellement accusé d'avoir agressé
lino saputo monuments commémoratifs jean-pierre
Shyvana est un expert de la mafia il a
collaboré à la grande
enquête provinciale sur le crime organisé dans les
années 70
c'est cool je veux dire qu'elle connaissait le groupe
Connecticut  Olivia Lisa faisant de la
fidélité Justin ici
Oh sans effet spécial le cube était
immoral s Paulo love Yoli a finalement été
blanchi de la charge  es pour avoir agressé
lino saputo, les témoins avaient
étrangement reculé même si viola avait été
identifié comme son agresseur, ce qui n'a pas
empêché Leno saputo de socialiser avec
eux, il était aux funérailles du frère violas
en 1970 et au baptême de l'un des
enfants les plus âgés autour du  en même temps,
lino saputo a refusé d'être interviewé
pour cette histoire mais son avocat a
répondu par écrit à nos questions
sur ses liens avec Paulo viola et Vic
Patroni de tels liens sont inévitables lorsque
vous faites partie d'une petite communauté comme
la communauté italienne c'est surprenant
réponse étant donné que lino saputo faisait également
affaire avec
Viola et Cutrone II n'allons-nous pas à cette
organisation d'oreillers cilicia della assistée est descendue au
Québec au Canada Valley Park n'a pas
encore dit quelque chose que L ne peut pas voir
fait foutu et  Pas comme ça,
nous avons obtenu des centaines de rapports de police
sur le syndicat du crime Viola Cotrona,
plusieurs rapports décrivent des réunions
entre les deux mafias.  eaders et lino
Sapporo qui leur donnait des conseils sur
leur entreprise de pepperoni
[Musique]
saputo distribuait également leurs
produits à la fin des années 70,
ses collègues de la CBC l'ont interrogé sur ses
liens avec Vika tronie vous savez mr.
cotrona droite oui je sais mr.  Patroni je
sais que c'était un homme d'affaires je connais le
premier ministre je connais beaucoup beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de charge je connais des avocats je suis un
homme d'affaires
qui avait été
identifié comme son agresseur d'autant plus
que dans son livre lino saputo
prend grand soin de condamner le
crime organisé mon père et mon grand-
père maternel m'ont élevé à ne jamais faire de mal
aux autres ou à m'impliquer avec des gens
qui ont eu recours à la violence ont été respectés
la loi a été respectée  notre éloignement des
organisations criminelles et éviter de croiser les
mauvaises personnes ne jamais s'impliquer avec des
gens qui ont recours à la violence garder ses
distances avec les organisations criminelles
lino saputo a oublié de mentionner sa
relation avec Viola et cutroni
mais ce n'était pas le seul oubli
[Musique]
toi
mon père est décédé le 8 juin 1981 son
absence m'a beaucoup pesé après
le décès de son père
valino saputo a repris la fa  entreprise
familiale et il avait des projets ambitieux
je l'ai vu devenir des transformateurs laitiers de premier ordre le
fromage saputo pourrait
devenir une multinationale
guerres et les gangsters auxquels il était
associé dans les années 60 et 70, mais
cette vidéo suivante raconte une histoire différente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors d'une réception de mariage, les invités dansent
au rythme de la chanson à succès de Michael Jackson, nous sommes en
1983,
le nom du marié est Donald Cote son
la mariée est Baba vous fait bâiller mais
rembobinons la bande la vidéo obtenue
par une source confidentielle commence
avec l'heureux couple vivant apparemment une
existence paisible à la campagne
mais qu'a fait Donald Kuti pour
vivre afin de découvrir que nous nous sommes penchés sur des
articles de journaux de  les années 60 70 et
80 à la Bibliothèque nationale de Montréal
on découvrait que Donnell Coty avait
souvent officialisé les manchettes  ly il
était un bijoutiers opposés amputés ont une
température
Roberto Burle le rêve c'est l'alerte d'abus
s'est produit à Rhoda rockin avec l'
affaire de la connaissance devrait partager le prix della
accusant ce que Farrah Clayton rarement l'
Italie avec la difficulté mr.  Krishna
l'homme était un criminel violent au
début des années 60, il a été reconnu coupable d'
avoir sauvagement agressé l'opposant politique d'un maire
dans une banlieue de Ventura.
une loi très lourde sur la laisse dans son
enfant a paniqué là-bas certainement P
personne que je veux juste Pender est venu
Kenzie, il a également été accusé et
reconnu coupable d'avoir importé illégalement des
diamants au Canada avec une
famille de légende complice utiliser un repas autour d'examiner
ce malveillant  une personne qu'il a également été
accusée dans deux affaires de meurtre distinctes mais qui a
été déclarée non coupable.
trafic de cocaïne, il a été innocenté de
ces accusations
au moment de son mariage, il
attendait son procès pour fraude impliquant
près d'un million de dollars, il n'a même pas reçu
une pomme de terre et des épitaphes sont
entrées alors  moi de l'argent et éjecté alvera Baba
vous avez Yom la femme nie que cootie ferait
que sa femme avait aussi un passé criminel
avant qu'elle ne change de nom
elle s'appelait Marie Louise Nolan elle
était complice de cooties dans l'
affaire de contrebande de diamants le couple était également
soupçonné de trafic de drogue
avance rapide jusqu'à la réception de mariage
[Musique]
voici lino saputo à la table des desserts
un homme d'affaires respectable mais pourquoi est-il
ici n'est-il pas fait lqt un associé connu
des joueurs les plus puissants de la mafia la
Kabbale enduite qui rapporte Mehmet si
elle Polly le comité politique  et et un
cadet a convenu du GOC effilé le
péruvien
rappelez-vous les propres mots de lino Sapporo ne jamais
s'impliquer avec des personnes qui recourent à la
violence garder une distance avec les organisations criminelles
il s'avère que leno sapporo n'est pas un
invité ordinaire à ce mariage
il est le meilleur homme de Donald cooties et  sa
femme Marella sapporo est la demoiselle
d'honneur de la mariée
[Musique]
à la réception Lina Sapporo et sa
femme sont assis à la tête t  Nous avons pu
envoyer des questions à Lino Sapporo sur sa
relation avec Donnell Kuti. La
réponse écrite de ses avocats n'a fait aucune mention
de l'affaire.
[Musique] Les
jeunes mariés sont heureux que la fête se
termine. Les gens dansent.
a découvert que lino
saputo avait des liens encore plus étroits avec l'un des
gangsters les plus notoires de l'
histoire des États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
luenell sapporo ne parle pas souvent
aux médias
mais nous nous sommes rencontrés en 2007 alors qu'il donnait des
interviews niant ses liens avec
le crime organisé
Marci un pré  -k Considération Budokan quand
il est associé à la mafia Lena
saputo s'empresse de le rejeter les gens ont obtenu
un ce que Jaime court ils prient ou ont fait
disparaître la mafia il s'est associé avec saputo a
lava be saputo okay ol entourage
selon l'homme d'affaires les fausses
allégations  découle d'un événement qui a eu
lieu dans les années 60 dans lequel il dit que c'était une
erreur sur par de la Nicoise notre dette
n'était pas un chat
nous sommes désolés certains que kima Vera était-il
nea  r l'
équipe pauvre du parc MV Shabana n'a pas participé
à un autre visa Depok mr.  Bonanno
n'était autre que Joe Bonanno, l'un des
gangsters les plus puissants d'Amérique,
corruption, trafic de drogue et meurtre,
et c'est ce que disait la lettre, cher
m.  Bonanno, il nous a été très utile
au fil des ans en nous informant que nous sommes
prêts à vous donner un total de 20% dans
ces entreprises sur votre investissement d'
environ 8 000 $ au moment où Joe
Bonanno essayait d'immigrer au
Canada avec l'aide du suppose mais
huit jours après que la lettre a été écrite, le
nom des bananes est apparu dans les nouvelles, poursuit en justice
dit quand j'ai compté Odyssey 20
Kennedy et je me sens libre de voir que vous avez
besoin
ou supposez que dimanche ne sera pas l'
organisation de Pâques Cosa Nostra alors que vous créez une
zone de carte voir Larry  pootis tu t'appelles Ivana
non ouais ouais Madonna douce Allah oui
Jermaine transfert a obtenu un Fed Lee non
sapporo a donné cette explication à
plusieurs reprises aucun lien avec Joe Bonanno
après 1964 mais l'histoire ne semble tout
simplement pas s'éloigner de nos tentatives d'investir dans
les marchés de l'Ontario, du Vermont et de l'
État de New York ont échoué en grande partie à cause des a
légations criminelles que l
s médias nous avaient précédemment épinglées. quelles étaient ces a
légations criminelles que s'est-il pass
au  audiences aux états-unis  nous voulions
savoir prochaine étape la bibliothèque d'Albany
New York au début des années 80 Leno saputo a
demandé une licence laitière mais le
département de l'agriculture de l'État de New York
s'y est opposé et a tenu des audiences pour
clarifier la relation entre saputo
et Joe Bonanno
[Musique  ]
encore une fois ces détenteurs toutes les preuves
et les témoignages des audiences ont été
conservés sur ces feuilles de plastique les
pages se comptent par milliers
cette simple affaire administrative est devenue
une enquête à part entière la police de
plusieurs États américains le FBI ainsi que
les autorités canadiennes ont certainement été impliqués
rapport important était que j'ai
trouvé que l'audience avait duré dix jours
plusieurs témoins ont été appelés à témoigner,
y compris le gène Eman qui avait apparemment
des informations cruciales, il était un
enquêteur travaillant en Arizona où
Joe Bonanno vit,
nous avons décidé de le rencontrer fait creamer
c'est le témoin clé dans  le
gène de cas Eman, ancien agent du FBI,
il travaillait alors pour l'ordre de tâche de l'Arizona Drug
Control qu  iet je pense que vous
appelleriez ça une
[musique] très sûre
Jeanne Eman nous guide à travers le
quartier de Tucson où vivait le chef du crime Joe
Bonanno l'ancien agent était l'un
des rares à passer les menottes à
Bonanno après avoir passé des années à
enquêter sur lui Sierra Vista
ce  est 231 son adresse est 255 et
c'est à peu près là où cette grande
poubelle est à environ 100 mètres
et sa maison va être sur la
droite ici c'est juste
ici est la maison où vivait le chef de file de la mafia
Joe Bonanno et c'est là que le gène
Eman et  son équipe a mené une
opération de surveillance inhabituelle dans les années 70
ils sont passés par la poubelle de Joe bonanno
il y aurait deux canettes galvanisées à la
place de ce récipient en plastique
côte à côte les enquêteurs ont sabré
les éboueurs ont mené leur
opération secrète sur une période de trois ans
ces photos  montrer à quel point leurs
actions devaient être précises, ils avaient 45 secondes
pour accomplir le gène de la tâche et un collègue
officier se cachait à l'intérieur de cette camionnette sur
tra  sh collectionnant les jours où ils passeraient
devant la maison de Joe bonanno, je tendrais la main pour
ramasser la boîte, la tirer à l'
arrière de la facture de la camionnette, sortirais les sacs Bonanno,
mettrais les sacs de remplacement
et je remettrais les canettes sur le
freiner après que nous ayons obtenu cela, puis nous partons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'ils ont ramassé dans les ordures a été
déchiré notes Joe banana était un
chef du crime très organisé, il faisait toujours
des listes bien, nous avons appris à la fois en l'
étudiant et  en le regardant qu'il
était le mafieux le plus puissant
des États-Unis et qu'il avait une influence spécifique,
nous avons appris au Canada que des notes manuscrites de bananes
avaient été reconstituées dans un
endroit caché à l'arrière d'un
magasin de meubles à Tucson à partir de ces
notes, nous avons commencé à développer des modèles
de lui, il a appelé le Canada assez
fréquemment,
pourquoi faisait-il tous ces appels au
Canada, nous avons finalement découvert en
ramassant les notes qu'il avait un
intérêt financier caché dans le
fromage saputo et que c'était un secret int  erest
qui a été tenu à l'écart du public
[Music]
finalement la police avait suffisamment de
preuves pour obtenir un mandat de perquisition pour les
bananes à la maison
ces boîtes de documents saisies l'année
était 1979 mais plus de recherches dans sa
poubelle conduiraient à de nouvelles informations
trois jours après notre recherche  nous avons
consciencieusement sorti ses poubelles et mis
1 200 autres notes qu'il avait manifestement paniqué
et voulait se débarrasser de ces
documents qui, comme nous l'avons maintenant découvert, le
reliaient encore plus profondément dans ses
relations avec le fromage saputo des
documents montrent que la
relation de Joe bonanno avec lino  saputo était en
cours, ils semblaient non seulement faire
affaire les uns avec les autres, mais aussi très
amicaux, ils semblaient interagir très
facilement les uns avec les autres, ils venaient d'avoir une
relation et cela faisait longtemps que
Jean Eman et ses collègues officiers ont recueilli
plusieurs autres éléments de preuve.  sur
saputo j'ai une copie de ces notes
j'ai un ensemble de toutes ces notes nous avons été
invités chez Jeanne Emmons
[Musique]
donc  ce sont toutes vos archives personnelles
donc vous n'avez pas vu ces cartons depuis plus de
30 ans 37 ans Jean voulait
nous attendre avant de se replonger dans l'
enquête il venait de récupérer ses
anciens documents ces documents tiers
cours de français vous savez il
parait certainement que  c'est au moins une partie de
la documentation que saputo
fournit à Joe Bonanno probablement
sur arrangement ou sur demande pour montrer
ce qui se passait dans le fromage saputo
[Musique]
non seulement Joe Bonanno avait des
états financiers pour une entreprise supposée mais le
mot liquide  Oh l'italien pour de l'argent en espèces
apparaît fréquemment dans les notes de bananes
sur saputo la police a également trouvé cet
article important à la poubelle
c'était un emballage de 1000 $ d'argent
il faisait partie d'un transfert d'argent de 51 000 $
selon la police l'argent provenait
d'entreprises  lié à saputo
pour juger charles queue brillante ce n'était
pas une simple spéculation policière le juge
queue brillante était un magistrat respecté il avait
passé 12 ans  s en tant que juge en chef de la
Cour d'appel de l'État de New York
lorsqu'il a pris sa retraite, il a dirigé l'
audience administrative sur
la demande de permis laitier de lino Sapporo, elle
s'est tenue à Albany en 1980 dans cette même
salle. Le juge Charles Bright Ella était le
juge et il a entendu les deux parties essentiellement
de notre côté et nous avons été interrogés par
les avocats de saputo x et il a
été déterminé que Bonanno avait
une relation avec le fromage saputo
Héros de la Commission sur le crime organisé au Québec, ils n'ont vu aucune preuve pouvant
justifier une enquête sur le supposé,
mais ce n'était pas suffisant pour influencer le juge
brillant et ils se sont vu refuser leur
demande pour faire des affaires à New York,
ce qui a été un énorme succès parce qu'ils étaient
traitant déjà plusieurs millions de
dollars d'affaires
dans ses mémoires lino saputo lunettes sur
ces événements uniquement pour remercier les personnes
qui testent  ifié en son nom le juge a
fini par rejeter nos demandes mais j'ai
été touché par leur geste il ne
mentionne jamais les histoires lumineuses du juge décision accablante la
queue brillante a conclu que
banana détenait des actions de diverses sociétés
appartenant à saputo Joseph Bonanno a
eu une implication économique et
transactionnelle importante sur une
période d'années avec plusieurs
entreprises fromagères canadiennes détenues par des
membres de la famille saputo et par lino
saputo en particulier les enjeux étaient très
élevés très élevés
a également conclu que lino saputo
avait menti lino saputo a tenté de
dissimuler au ministère son implication et celle de son
entreprise avec la banane et
a fait des déclarations matérielles qui sont
fausses, trompeuses et mensongères l'une de
ces fausses déclarations concernait une
réunion secrète enregistrée par le FBI dont
lino  saputo n'avait aucun souvenir, on
constate comme un fait que  contrairement à ses
affirmations, lino et sa femme ont rencontré
Bonanno à Tucson au début des années 1970,
font une carte de la région sur la réputation d'une
missive oh non non ouais ouais la mort de Madonna
oui le transfert de Jermaine a obtenu un Fed les
documents que le gène Ammon et ses collègues
officiers ont pu  mis la main
sont la preuve que la relation
entre les deux hommes s'est prolongée
au moins jusqu'à la fin des années 70, mais ce n'est pas tout
.
[Musique]
vous
nous sommes de retour à Tucson Arizona essayiez
de joindre Pepe Fredo par téléphone
ce nom de cône et ce numéro de téléphone reviennent
plusieurs fois dans les notes de Joe bonanno
concernant lino saputo à la fin des années 70
pas de réponse
qui est ce Pepe  Fredo qui semble être
si important pour l'enquête de Jean Hammond
avec l'aide de la GRC
Ammon devait découvrir la véritable identité de l'homme,
nous avions donc ces noms liés
aux numéros de téléphone et au  n la GRC a
déterminé à qui appartenaient les numéros de téléphone
et cela nous a révélé qui
il
parlait Pepi Fredo est un membre de la
famille Sapporo il vit toujours dans le même
manoir luxueux à Montréal c'est un
homme d'affaires de premier plan et nous vous dirons
peu de temps qui il est
[Musique]
mais d'abord nous avons obtenu une vidéo qui n'a
jamais été montrée au public une preuve rare qui nous a été
donnée par une
source confidentielle
[Musique]
il montre une réunion de famille chez les
Rizzuto à Montréal
ces images ont été  prise lors de la fête du 50e
anniversaire de mariage de Nicola
Rizzuto et libet's na mano en 1995 à
l'époque où
Nakano Rizzuto n'était autre que le
parrain du crime organisé au Canada l'
un des points forts de la vidéo est
cette scène surréaliste où les musiciens embauchés
commencent à jouer un  accordez-vous au plus grand plaisir
des invités alors qu'ils attendent que le
couple anniversaire apparaisse alors que la
famille se dirige vers l'extérieur, le groupe
commence à jouer le thème de The
Godfather
[Music]
the Ri  les zzuto affichent ouvertement leur
statut mafieux Pepe Fredo dont le nom apparaissait dans
les notes de Joe bonanno est un invité à la
fête dans son livre lino saputo mentionne
cet homme une fois aussi nous l'avons trouvé meilleur
notre bras immobilier maintenant l'une des
plus grandes sociétés immobilières privées au
Québec  avec plus de 8,3 millions de pieds carrés
de propriété à Montréal mon cher ami
et beau-frère
Giuseppe Borsellino est président Jusuf
Borsalino également connu sous le nom de Pepe Fredo il est
marié à la soeur d'Alina saputo Lina il est
peut-être moins connu que son
beau-frère
mais joosep Eber Cellino est un
magnat de l'immobilier à Montréal Borsalino est
impliqué dans les entreprises de soutien
depuis les années 60
[Musique]
jeanna signifie que l'enquête sur
les déchets de Joe bonanno montre clairement que
joosep Eber Selena était l'intermédiaire
entre lino saputo et banana
J'aimerais si  possible d'entendre la voix de
votre beau-frère et de lui parler
bien qu'il n'ait jamais été formellement accusé
de meurtre
Jill banana était connue comme une puissante
criminel,
nous savions que Bonanno qui avait une
relation avec le saputo z - et le
bar Salinas était crédité de 80 meurtres,
certains d'entre eux lui-même, la
plupart d'entre eux ayant ordonné et donc c'était un
gars violent et il avait une relation avec
eux
Giuseppe Borsalino et banane serait  parler
au téléphone ils organiseraient des réunions est-
ce que les gens me téléphonent
lundi soir 1er décembre 1975 à 19
heures  votre temps, il a noté
des horaires et des arrangements spécifiques avec
Borsalino, en particulier qu'il allait
l'appeler ou recevoir un appel à cette
cabine téléphonique à une heure particulière un
jour particulier et vous avez pu
confirmer que nous pouvions le confirmer
parce que nous  avait une surveillance sur ces
cabines téléphoniques la plupart du temps, la
cabine téléphonique qu'il utilisait était dans un
couloir d'hôpital
.  connaître la
conversation
cette lettre écrite par Borsalino au
milieu des années 70 à Joe Bonanno dit à
Giorgio je ne sais pas comment m'excuser
pour l'appel téléphonique je ne l'ai pas fait je
sais que les excuses sont inutiles mais je
vous assure que ce jour-là j'ai été retenu  au tribunal
pour une petite affaire j'ai demandé
pardon et compréhension permettez-moi
de vous fournir une photo de notre
fille afin que vous puissiez apprendre à la connaître
j'espère que cette lettre vous trouvera bien vous et votre
famille et jusqu'à ce que nous parlions  au
téléphone je présente mes salutations les plus chaleureuses
les notes de bananes montrent également que les deux hommes ont
parlé d'argent appeler Pepe Fredo parler
de la grève des lettres et du lakitu et de l'
argent à Montréal nous essayons à nouveau d'appeler
le numéro de téléphone de Pepe freddo qui a été
trouvé dans Joe les bananes ont déchiré les notes  comme
vous l'avez dit, les gens ont dit qu'il sait qui
vous a innocenté Tsubasa dans Madame Septim, le témoin
Guiseppe Borsellino a toujours le même
numéro de téléphone qu'il a refusé de nous
parler ainsi qu'alline saputo dans une
réponse écrite pour l'avocat de cellino qui nie tout
acte répréhensible de la part de ses clients dans sa
boîte  des dossiers de police Jeana man a trouvé
le récit d'une conversation entre
les autorités de l'Arizona et les autorités canadiennes
datant de 1976 concernant lino saputo
et Giuseppe Borsellino zapatos sont
connus comme des personnalités du crime organisé et
font l'objet d'une enquête
depuis un an qu'ont fait les
autorités canadiennes de tous  cette preuve que
vous avez recueillie dans la poubelle de Joe bonanno et
bien ils je sais qu'ils ont mené un
raid sur la maison de Sapporo  Je ne sais pas quel en a été
le résultat, mais en termes de
suivi, je ne sais pas s'il y en a eu,
mais je ne peux pas parler de tout ce que fait la
GRC, mais pour autant que nous sachions, c'était
la fin
lino  Sapporo et Giuseppe Borsalino n'ont
jamais fait l'objet d'accusations criminelles.
Montréal les représentants du
clan Bonanno à Montréal Paulo vol II
et Vic atrani étaient morts Nicola Rizzuto
et son fils Vito avaient pris la relève lors de leur
fête d'anniversaire de mariage ils ont accueilli
chez eux des amis proches dont
des criminels de haut rang comme ce
trafiquant d'héroïne condamné ils  prenez également des
photos avec les invités, quelques chanceux
peuvent poser à côté du parrain
lui-même parmi lesquels
Elena saputo et joosep Eber Cellino
également connu sous le nom de Pepe Fredo selon
documents de police giuseppe Borsellino a
poursuivi ses contacts avec les membres du
clan rizzuto jusqu'au moins au
milieu des années 2000, nous avons demandé à lino saputo de venir
et la relation de son beau-frère
avec les Rizzuto, il n'a pas répondu à la
question
Marisa généralement TDC sous le PDG de puta
Privilèges a dit qu'il n'y avait pas de réputation
pourquoi lino saputo a toujours menti sur
sa relation avec le plus haut
échelon du crime organisé nous n'avons
vendu aucune action à m.  banane pourquoi alors qu'il a
nié avoir des liens avec le crime organisé,
les
gens se rassemblent et voient un shammy Shraddha
prier ou diluant da mafia il s'associe avec
saputo a lava be saputo arrogant ancien
entourage ce peuple car il
aurait sûrement entaché le nom de sapporo dans
les milieux d'affaires de  lino saputo sa
nomination au conseil d'administration de
la Banque Nationale où il a siégé pendant 10
ans à l'influence de Sapporo en
politique giuseppe Borsellino a été un
collecteur de fonds officiel pour le
Parti libéral provincial du Québec aux nombreuses
récompenses comme ce doctorat honorifique de
l'Université Concordia les nombreuses
distinctions honorifiques lino saputo uno de
Pape québécois Revo fan aficionado
aniseh knowledge donné ou les
plus hautes distinctions du pays comme l'Ordre du Canada
décerné par le gouverneur général woodley
aucun saputo n'aurait été célébré par les
Canadiens s'il avait dit la vérité sur
ses liens passés avec les organisations  crime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique
] c'était une présentation spéciale en anglais
de l'OCAD H
programme d'enquête ozuki nadas merci d'avoir regardé
[Musique]
vous